Couple things to show you ,first let
me just show you this kind of works.
Allright, here's some optic flow results
taken from a computer vision class 2003
from a actually it's a tutorial.
Here listed on the bottom and you can
see that when you run loops at the,
on that front tree without kermits,
you get sort of terrible results and
while when you run it with the pyramid
you get a much better result.
And our goal is to really
get that much better result.
But before we can do this we have
to talk a little bit more about
multiple scale.
So we been having all this
multiple scale stuff.
Now this isn't going to surprise
you that it relates to some of
the aliasing stuff and frequency
stuff that we talked about, oh God,
sounds like, found,
feels like months ago.
It's probably months ago.
I have no idea when it was.
Anyway when we were talking about
Fourier analysis in different scale.
And what we're going to do now is take
a little detour through multi scale and
then we'll come back to Lucas and
Canoti.
Allright, so,
we talked about aliasing, and
now I want to show you aliasing in,
in terms of image sub-sampling, okay?
So image sub-sampling is what,
we talked about it,
you just throw away
some number of pixels.
So here we have a a nice,
I sure hope it's in public domain,
picture by Van Gogh.
This is one where you can see his ear.
So on the other side,
I guess, there's no ear.
You know about that, right?
I'm going to assume you have
some experience with Van Gogh.
Anyway, okay, fine.
So, the picture on the left is
original picture where I've
thrown away every sample.
Maybe you can't tell.
Picture in the middle I've thrown away.
Every other sample, again,
both horizontally and vertically.
The picture on the right,
I've done it again.
Eve, I can tell, you probably
can't tell, I can tell it's,
kind of, looking kind of crummy.
And, in fact, if I blow up that
picture on the right, I see this.
Okay?
And what you're seeing here, the, the
junk that's in here is caused by this,
this aliasing, like just what we talked
about last time and, when I zoom it
back up, you can see that you've brought
these high-frequencies in there and
there's all this stuff in here that
just doesn't seem like it's the blurry
version of what was in the original and
that's because it's not.
It's an aliased example.
So, how do we handle aliasing?
What we talked about this last time.
What we have to do is we have
to filter and then sub sample.
So what I've done now is I've taken a
small Gaussian smoothing in the original
sub sampled.
Then smooth it again and sub sample.
And now when I blow it back up you'll
notice that the Gaussian sample then
that actually looks like a blurred
version of the thing on the left.
Okay, and that's because I
haven't done any aliasing.
So to do this multi-scale
stuff the right way,
I have to sort of do this blurring and
subsampling.